game one of the american league wild
card series the rays returning to
postseason for the second year in a row
tonight it's game one of a best of three
against the toronto blue jays blake
snell is the ace he's had a little
trouble getting rolling but he feels
like he is ready to go and here is
biggio
and he chased
that's exactly where they want to throw
that guy up
with velocity get him to chase and he
hasn't
he will he will get to the point where
he'll start laying off that pitch
understanding that he can't get it now a
mana board and that'll bring up vladimir
guerrero
snell breaking ball gets him
blake snell's in the house
blue jays and ray's underway scoreless
headed to the bottom of the first match
shoemaker a surprise starter just six
starts oh and two with two outs
and a runner at first
runner goes
little chopper over the mound buchet has
it
and gets the outs
shoemaker the oscar 289 16 homers
fastball 96. he can dial it up when he
needs it jonathan vr switch hitter
and there is that wipeout breaking ball
four strikeouts through two for blake
snow danny janssen number nine man in
the order just three for 21 against the
rays this year chance in the situation
to do their job look at that rips one to
left
and a running catch there by a rosarito
and here is kevin biggio the left-hander
throws he struck him out swinging
another fastball up and away this time
five strikeouts through ten batters no
hits yet so far it is a pitcher's dual
and matt shoemaker has given up just a
couple of soft singles he takes the
mound to begin the bottom of the third
inning against the nine hitter mike
zanino oh two swinging a miss got him
with a slider a three pitch strikeout
for matt shoemaker who gets through the
raise
order first time on just 27 pitches now
facing yoshi tsugo for a second time a 3
14 on base
he swings and misses at a high fast ball
two strikeouts on six pitches for matt
shoemaker
came off the injured list second week of
september arrow junior in a scoreless
game fourth inning one and two the count
snell out of his wind up to that pain to
throw
swinging a missing struck him out at a
slider in the dirt blocked by zanino
lobs to throw to first and that's six
strikeouts already for blake snail one
going and here's kritchik now snell in
the 2-2 pitch fastball struck him out
swinging two down
blake snell humming through the blue
jays order
seven strikeouts snell looks just
dominant right now yes he does
he's punched out the last three
rolled up the middle
adamus
and guerrero is out and snell goes one
two three
this is robbie ray and so shoemaker
outstanding through three innings randy
rosarina the three hitter
got on top of that one drills it in the
gap right center hernandez to the wall a
rosarina can run around second on his
way to third relay
not in time and the rays get a triple to
open the fourth adamus
you ask yourself how these situations
they execute ball gets away arose arena
coming and he scores
rays take a one-nothing lead ball
squirted away from janssen back behind
the plate on ball four he didn't go to
the backstop it went about maybe halfway
to the backstop and jansen went after it
quickly but rosarina committed early
and the rays take
an early lead let's see if blake has a
shutdown inning in him against lotus
guriel jr first
i think he went and he knows he did but
the ball rolls away from zunino
who is up to get it and throw him out
that's eight strikeouts
snell a no-hitter through five alejandro
kirk do some special things and
there goes the no no in the right fields
and that's a base hit no hitter over
kirk is aboard here's kevin vicio he
struck out twice
check swing strike three calls three
strikeouts of biggio nine strikeouts now
for snell and he's just been dylan i
mean he's he's been filthy all night and
his night comes to an end but i mean you
can't ask for anything more out of blake
they really have something here in a
rose arena
robbie ray dials it up
and throws it by him
robbie ray
is throwing the ball well
got him outside corner that's eight in a
row for robbie ray in a one-run game
anderson comes in
first and second for the jays this is
panic in a big spot 0-2 line drive
stabbed there by adamus in the shift
panic hit it on the button adamus got it
before it hit the turf and the blue jays
leave two wendell be held on by guerrero
at first and here's manuelmar ghost
wendell blufft
ball's hit well left field back goes
gorilla it is gone manuel margot in his
postseason debut launches a two-round
homer and the rays take the
three-nothing lead flat fastball nice
easy swing lines rod gets out here
and don't look now but the blue jays are
bringing the tying run to the plate
trying to make it a whole new ball game
as beau bechet comes to the plate he's
over three
pachette to right field
margot there tellez doesn't have great
speed he's coming home throws up the
line and he's gonna score
and though bechet delivers a run the
blue jays are on the board it's a
two-run game let's try to find a way to
push one more across
oh another line drive that finds the
glove of adamus
boy the blue jays have hidden some tough
luck that was on the nose from grichik
fairbanks is on to try to get a save run
on second now they have a chance to tie
the bargain
a little jam shot
wendell is there and he makes the catch
and the tampa bay rays have captured
game one